If I choose to do a vitamin C IVs, what milligram do I start with?
So, you'll want to take the advice of the IV setter,
but they're going to push you to do high dose.
I don't think it's ever good to start there.
So, if you could start with 20 grams,
it depends on, so they buy the packs in certain milligrams sets.
So, it might be a 20,000 milligram,
then they'll go to 40, they'll go to 60,
then they'll go to 80, or it's 25 to 50 to 75.
So, it depends on how they have their sets.
So, I can't say do 15,000 or 15 grams
if they don't buy bags of 15 grams,
the lowest they have is 25 grams.
Certainly do not start more than 25 grams
that you work up to 50 to 75 grams.
Partly, it depends on your weight.
So, if you're 140 pounds,
maybe the most you're going to do is 50 grams.
If you're 240 pounds, maybe you'll go up to 75 grams.
I've had people that said they're higher than that,
but I don't think there's any evidence that that's necessary.